We can do this by modifying the listcomponentsizes
algorithm from the previous example. Call
the algorithm check connection, and it takes
a graph, but it also takes v1 and v2.It's
going to do something similar to before. It's
going to start off with the assumption that
none of the nodes have been marked so far
as reachable. Then we're going to call marked
component on that graph, and the node that
we're going to start marking from is v1. And
what that's going to do when this returns--it's
going to return a number, but we're just going
to ignore it-- it's going to go through starting
at v1 and mark, like basically touch, every
node that can be reached from v1. And we want
to find out whether or not there's a connection
to v2, and that's really easy at this point.
The answer is v2 in. So what this does is
it checks whether the node v2 that we've been
given as input was one of the nodes that got
marked when we were spreading things out from
v1. So it starts at v1, spreads things through
the graph like some kind of an infection or
a good idea, and when that's all through,
all we have to do is look to see whether v2
was one of the things that got infected in
the spread. So according to this, a and g
are connected. Let's take a look back at the
graph. g is reachable from a, but that's not
so exciting to think about because they were
pretty much connected directly. Let's try
a more interesting one, say h and b. It realizes
that h and b are in fact connected, and that's
more interesting because it requires multiple
hops to get from one to the other. And then
finally, we can do a and b. We know that they're
in different components because remember,
there was component a with 4 nodes and component
b with 4 nodes, but let's make sure that the
program can figure that out. Yes, indeed.
So when it spread things out from a and reached
everywhere it could reach, b was not among
the visited.